es war eine unglaubliche tat von
tapferkeit und heldenmut die sich heute
in unserer welt ereignete in der
kenianischen grenzregion mandera kam es
zu einem bewaffneten angriff von
anhängern der islamischen
terrororganisation al shabab auf einen
reisebus
ziel des attentats war die ermordung der
christlichen passagiere
[Musik]
die route zwischen nairobi und madeira
66 jahren von 20 12 20 15 10 brachen wir
nachts in nairobi auf und verbrachten
die darauffolgende nacht als
zwischenstopps am pool am nächsten
morgen um 6 uhr 30 fuhren wir weiter als
etwa gegen 37 zwischen kultur und l wack
angegriffen worden
da ich weit außerhalb von nairobi wohne
kauft sich mein bus ticker bereits am 19
dezember da der bus nairobi erst in der
nacht auf den 20
dezember verlassen sollte bat ich den
fahrer um einen schlafplatz empfahl mir
ein nahe gelegenes hotel aber das konnte
ich mir nicht leisten und ich hatte
angst zu verschlafen
daher bot mir der fahrer an man hinten
im bus zu übernachten und man wie sind
sie noch die man das gepäck eingeladen
hatte legt den ich mich also worauf die
hinteren sitze des busses schlafen und
übernachtet
so verbrachte ich die nacht
[Musik]
mandela ist wirklich eine äußerst
interessante stadt was sie liegt an der
nordöstlichen grenze kenias und grenzt
an äthiopien und somalia
wenn sie möchten können sie also in
kenia frühstücken den äthiopien ihr
mittagessen einnehmen und in somalia zu
abend essen auch deshalb ist man der us
gesellschaftliche und wirtschaftliche
struktur schon immer stark von diesen
nachbarstaaten geprägt wir müssen uns in
mann der vor allem eine herausforderung
stellen
der durch den islamischen terror
[Musik]
der bus fuhr um mitternacht los und wir
hatten unsere erste pause am nächsten
morgen in garissa ich bin ausgestiegen
weil ich etwas zum essen kaufen und zur
toilette gehen wollte auf dem weg kam
ich an einer gruppe somalischer männer
vorbei im vorbeigehen hörte ich wie sie
sich lautstark über mich unterhielten
und sich wunderten wohin ich als
christin wohl unterwegs sein
ich habe versucht sie zu generieren und
bin zurück zum bus
[Musik]
der bus verließ in jener nacht nairobi
wie üblich um mitternacht
nachdem wir einige zeit gefahren waren
erhielten wir für eine kurze strecke
eine polizei eskorte
[Musik]
lid
der grund warum man derer seit 2011
immer wieder für schlagzeilen sorgte ist
die beteiligung des kenianischen
militärs an operation lindern
es ist ein einsatz afrikanischer uno
truppen auf somalischen boden im kampf
gegen die al shabab als vergeltung für
kenias beteiligung verübte die al
shabaab zahlreiche anschläge in mann der
den auch immer wieder die
zivilbevölkerung zum opfer fielen
ich kam im februar 2013 nach madeira
dabei waren 2013 und 2014
die beiden schlimmsten jahre überhaupt
täglich kam es zu gefechten und
nächtlichen angriffen
ich lebte in der innenstadt von mansehra
jeden abend musstest du sicher gehen um
18 uhr in deinem haus zu sein
danach wurde es der pure alptraum an
jeder ecke der stadt kam es zum
feuergefecht mit
das militär war ein ständiger
alarmbereitschaft und die polizei jagte
die menschen durch die straßen
es gab zeiten da konnte man nachts nicht
im eigenen bett schlafen weil du nicht
wusstest ob kugeln durch ein fenster
schlagen würden also schliefen wir auf
dem boden
um sicher zu gehen dass die kugel nicht
uns sondern die gegenüberliegende wand
treffen würden
[Musik]
weil an diesem tag zu wenig busse auf
der strecke von nairobi nach mandela
unterwegs waren war unser bus besonders
voll
wir erreichten kultur um vier uhr
morgens um dort für eine längere pause
zu halten bevor wir die reise fortsetzen
[Musik]
apu ziel der terroristen ist es sich
hinter den lehren des muslimischen
glaubens zu verstecken
sprechen sie jedoch mit muslimen und
ihren gelehrten
so werden sie sehr deutlich sagen dass
ihr glaube nichts mit dem der
terroristen zu tun hat wir glauben an
die vielfalt der religionen und kulturen
dies wären wir unseren kindern und
schülern zuerst einmal ist jeder einfach
ein mensch darum sagt uns der islam alle
gemeinsam als eine familie zu leben
tötest du einen menschen egal wen ist es
als hättest du alle getötet die steht im
koran
die al shabaab wählte die ziele ihrer
anschläge sehr bewusst und strategisch
ihnen ging es nicht nur darum zu töten
sondern vor allem wollte sie misstrauen
und zwietracht zwischen den menschen in
den verschiedenen teilen unseres landes
sehen in erster linie vielleicht aus
religiösen gründen aber sicher auch aus
ökonomischen
[Musik]
es stellte sich heraus dass die
terroristen nach einem weg suchen die
gesellschaft zu spalten
es ging ihnen darum christen und muslime
gegeneinander aufzubringen um selbst
ihren vorteil daraus zu ziehen sobald es
so ausgesehen hatte als ob grundsätzlich
muslime christen umbringen würden
hofften sie dass die christen antworten
würden und ebenfalls beginnen würden
muslime zu töten sie wollten es zu einem
religionskrieg werden lassen
[Musik]
um vier uhr morgens erreichen wir kultur
und hielten an einer raststätte der bus
war sehr voll viele leute liebten sich
auf teppiche mal ein bisschen schlaf zu
bekommen
um sechs uhr morgens weckte uns unser
busfahrer und fordert uns auf wieder
einzusteigen unsere reise fortzusetzen
[Musik]
da wir an diesem tag der einzige bus
waren war er völlig überfüllt dies
geschieht immer wenn an tagen nur ein
einziger bus fährt weil es also
nirgendwo mehr platz gab kletterte ich
auf das dach des busses und fuhr auf dem
gepäckträger mit
im fokus weil die straße auf diesen teil
der strecke sehr schlecht ist durch
besonders langsam immer wieder gab es
schlaglöcher und tiefe gräben durch die
wir fuhren wir waren gerade dabei einen
dieser gräben zu umfahren und ich
bremste ab als plötzlich leute aus dem
gebüsch auftauchten
candreva plötzlich gab unser fahrer gas
zuerst dachte ich es wäre nur wegen der
unebenen straße aber dann bremste der
bus ab ich konnte eine gruppe menschen
auf der straße erkennen wie aus dem
nichts fielen schüsse
das erste was mir durch den kopf er war
was aus den passagieren auf dem
gepäckträger wird
[Musik]
ich dachte zuerst dass es sich um
kenianische soldaten handelt aber als
sie anfängen auf uns schießen und uns
umzingeln
und als sich ihre verhüllten gesichter
sagt da wusste ich dass wir angegriffen
wurden wir waren noch nicht lange
unterwegs als ich plötzlich schüsse
hörte das ist das ende dachte ich sofort
und legte mein schicksal in gottes hände
[Musik]
2013 und 2014 ist einfach zu viel
passiert
es wurden zu viele menschen in der
bevölkerung opfer von terrorattacken
die meisten von denen die bei den
attentaten die ihr leben verloren waren
christen den höhepunkt erreichten die
attacken schließlich 2014
danach kam es zum ende auch unsere
schule bekam die auswirkungen der
zahlreichen angriffe zu spüren
wir sind ein kollegium aus lehrern
verschiedener ethnien und religionen
auch wenn man derer die mehrheit muslime
sind unterrichten bei uns zahlreiche
christen 2014 hatten wir fünf
christliche lehrer die ursprünglich
nicht aus dieser gegend kam auch wenn
sie von den attentaten damals nicht
direkt betroffen waren begannen sie um
ihr leben zu fürchten und kamen
schließlich im januar 2015 nicht aus
ihrem urlaub zurück
[Musik]
sie befallen uns die türen zu öffnen
zu diesem zeitpunkt hatten alle
passagiere auf dem boden des busses
schutz gesucht
wir standen unter schock sind keine
erwartest dem befehl zu folgen
die angreifer richteten ihre
maschinengewehre aufs fenster und
schrien macht auf oder wir schießen euch
alle
erst da öffnete ich die tür und wir
stiegen langsam aus ich war ganz hinten
im bus und alle riefen durcheinander
ich hörte einen mann der rief auf
suaheli steigt aus kindern steigt aus
als ich das hörte stand ich schnell auf
und wollte so schnell wie möglich aus
dem bus es waren zu viele leute vor mir
es war zu voll
ich kam einfach nicht durch im bus
befanden sich sowohl christen als auch
muslime
wir waren eine sehr gemischte gruppe
schnelle riefen wir den muslimen zu dass
sie den christinnen eines ihrer langen
gewänder geben sollten das taten sie
sofort es war so voll dass ich mich
wieder hingesetzt habe
da steckt und wie schnell ein älterer
mann von weiter hinten im bus an
funktionen sagte dass ich mich damit
bedecken soll es danach steigt alle
sofort aus sonst werden diese leute uns
hier im bus erschießen
ich lag wie versteinert auf dem dach des
busses und wagt kaum zu atmen als die
terroristen den bus stürmten
sie trieben die leute aus dem bus und
zwangen sie auf die knie
dann begannen sie unter ihnen nach
christen zu suchen ich erinnere mich
dass ich ein passagier von der gruppe
löste sorgen könnten
wir standen alle auf einem haufen so eng
beisammen
christen und muslime die angreifer
schrieben dass wir die christen
herausgeben sollten doch wir antworteten
dass es unter uns keine christen gibt
sie bezahlen uns noch einmal auf die
christen unter uns zu zeigen aber wir
blieben ruhig und haben nur gesagt wir
haben keine christen bei uns wenn wir
uns erschießen wollte dann erschießt uns
sind keine christen unter uns der junge
mann der als erster ausgestiegen ist bei
ncr ist sehen wie die angreifer anfingen
ihn zu befragen
einer der männer der von den angreifern
verhört wurde sagte dass er vor zwei
monaten zum islam konvertiert ist
daraufhin befallen sie ihm ein
bestimmtes gebiet zu zitieren
er konnte ihrer frage nicht beantworten
und sie haben ihn erschossen lisa juli
umgesetzt haben sie ihn noch gefragt
wann er geboren wurde und in welchem
teil des landes er gab keine antwort und
versuchte zu fliehen
die angreifer riefen ihn zurück und in
dem moment als sie sich umdrehte
begannen sie zu schießen
er ist auf der stelle gestorben
[Musik]
unsere strategie war sie zu verwirren
wir haben den frauen gesagt dass sie
anderen frauen kleidung geben sollen bei
den männern ist es aber so dass wir
muslime oft keine spezielle kleidung
tragen
wir tragen einfach hemd und hose
[Musik]
von dieser geschichte zu hören machte
mich unglaublich glücklich
es bewies dass die menschen in mansehra
erkannt haben dass der terrorismus nicht
nur den christen unter ihnen schadet er
betrifft sie alle auch wenn weiterhin
grundsätzliche strukturelle und
politische veränderungen geschehen
müssen haben doch die menschen von
mandela selbst den ersten schritt in die
eigene zukunft getan
die ursachen liegen in der us geschichte
über jahre hinweg wurden menschen
ermordet die meisten von ihnen waren
zugezogene und nicht muss
dies hatte auswirkungen vor allem auf
schulen und krankenhäuser
die meisten ärzte in der region waren
christen die meisten lehrer in der
region plan christen als die attentate
auf sie begann floh der größte teil von
ihnen aus der region al shabaab hat die
soziale struktur dieser gegen zerstört
schulen und krankenhäuser betroffen die
medizinische versorgung brach zusammen
aber auch der zugang zu lebensmitteln
und wahn ist deutlich schwieriger
geworden
in dieser gegend zu arbeiten ist kaum
noch rentabel
aus diesen gründen war es die
bevölkerung selbst die eines tages sagte
es reicht in der wahrnehmung als wäre
der kampf der al shabab einer der so
marlies gegen die kenianer haben dies
eine absolute kehrtwende gleich
plötzlich war klar dass hier nicht die
somalis gegen kenianer kämpften
plötzlich war die al shabab isoliert
[Musik]
wir riefen wieder und wieder dass es
unter uns keine christen gibt an diesem
tag hat uns gott geholfen
wir waren eine einheit und es war für
die angreifer nicht erkennbar
der christ und wer muslim ist sie
konnten uns nicht trennen
irgendwann gaben sie auf und schrien
steigt wieder ein wie verrückt begann
mir daraufhin zurück zum bus zu rennen
[Musik]
es ist etwas das einfach passiert es ist
eine spontane reaktion einfach eine
energie die wohl von einer person
erzeugt wird und sich auf den rest der
gruppe überträgt in diesem fall
jedenfalls war es diese eine person und
dies war der lehrer von dem binnen
sprechen
er vereinte die gruppe und versammelte
sie um sich
[Musik]
es waren neun ungefähr 9
in zwei gruppen die einen von ihnen
waren noch weiter weg
anderen sage ich auf uns zu wenn der bus
anzuhalten
[Musik]
sala fahrer saß auf dem sitz direkt
hinter mir auf dem sitzplatz nummer 7
sofort beim angriff wurde der vordere
teil des busses von schüssen
durchlöchert überall die fenster die
türen der lehrer saß direkt hinter mir
und wurde von einer kugel getroffen
[Musik]
bitte lasst sie befallen uns dass
diejenigen die moslems waren aufstehen
sollten kaum zurück zum bus zu gehen was
[Musik]
sala fahrer stellte sich den terroristen
entgegen und schützte die christen
er sagte den islamisten ins gesicht wir
werden nicht zulassen dass ihr unsere
christlichen brüder und schwestern
ermordet
so wie er es in der vergangenheit
bereits zu oft getan hat
[Musik]
man kann sich nur verneigen stellen sie
sich vor sie hätten eine waffe an ihrem
kopf
stellen sie sich vor es wäre an ihnen
jemanden zu retten oder zu verraten
würden sie es tun was befähigt einen
menschen so etwas zu tun
[Musik]
mister salas abdul fahrer besser bekannt
als mister sala fahrer war ein lehrer an
dieser schule
er wurde angeschossen als er sich den
terroristen in den weg stellte um das
leben von christen zu retten
mir wurde gesagt weil er dies tat wurde
auf ihn geschossen und er wurde in den
rücken getroffen
er zahlte den preis und wurde
angeschossen nachdem er zur behandlung
ins krankenhaus kam konnte man ihn dort
nicht mehr retten er starb
es war dieser lehrer ich in meiner
erinnerung an ihn sehe ich diese bilder
diese
ich kann es nicht erklären sorry
a
bei uns in swahili gibt es ein
sprichwort man sagt schema haki dumm und
das heißt alles von wert von
wahrhaftigkeit bleibt uns nicht lang
dies ist der grund warum wir ihn an die
kugel verloren haben die die terroristen
auf ihn schossen
[Musik]
dieser tag sollte uns allen ein vorbild
sein
ein mensch der unter lebensgefahr
aufsteht um einen anderen menschen den
er nicht einmal kennt das leben zu
retten
das ist eine geschichte für die ewigkeit
überall auf der welt und doch musste
unser land viel grausames erdulden bevor
es bereit war für diesen moment
[Musik]